Okay, so glutamate is really important, because it causes a lot of problems.
Matter of fact, there's a new report that just came out a few weeks ago that excess
glutamate in your body converts directly to peroxidate trait.
So glutamate is not a good guy.
You need glutamate, right, so don't get me wrong, but almost everybody has excess glutamate,
especially if you have defects in this gene called your GAN gene.
Your GAN one gene, well, these two genes produce excess glutamate in your body, but this
is how you're supposed to take glutamate and convert it to GABA.
Glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter.
It's fine, I need to wake up, I need glutamate, right?
I need to learn, I need glutamate.
However, you have too much excitation of glutamate receptors in over and over and over again,
you have dementia.
You will burn out glutamate receptors.
There's a good book written on this called Neuroexcital Toxins, by Dr. Russell Blalock, he's
a neurologist who's converted to our side, and he writes a lot about glutamate.
Now, you've heard of glutamate in your diet, as they burn sodium glutamate in this gene, right?
But there's a whole bunch of different glutamates that, in fact, does not have to be labeled
anymore.
Thank you, FDA.
It's labeled as natural and artificial flavorings, because they are flavorings.
What they do is they excite the glutamate receptors on your tongue.
They're excitatory, they fire to your brain, and you go, that wasn't good, I'm going to
buy you another bag of those chips.
So they're found in processed foods, Chinese food, I went into a Chinese restaurant a couple
of years ago.
I was in a branch of Chinese restaurant next to a coffee shop in our hotel.
I said, hey, do you use MSG in your food?
He goes, I said, what?
I don't believe any Chinese restaurants, because they don't use MSG.
We don't sprinkle MSG on our food.
I don't think anybody does, but it all comes with MSG.
It all does.
So unless it's one of those restaurants that's making everything by scratch, it definitely has
MSG in it.
Because that's what makes it taste better.
Wow, I really like their foods, really good.
See, there are the spices, it's the wonderful, organic vegetables you're using, or it's the
MSG.
Because it's excitatory to your tongue, you want more of it, fires glutamate receptors
of the brain, it birds, and they're both.
It's also a lot cheaper than using good ingredients.
Oh, it's a lot cheaper than using good ingredients, exactly.
Yes.
So glutamate is not good in excess.
What do you have?
Gad genes.
Glutamate is supposed to convert to GABA.
But it does truth that through this gene, GABA is a culinary neurotransmitter.
You need GABA to fall asleep, and GABA to relax, to chill.
So people with excess glutamate don't do that very well.
So they're highly excitatory, it could cause anxiety.
Though I didn't talk about the serotonin of the bough gene, a person can have two little
serotonin, right?
They have depression.
So this, oh, gee, here, I have those defects.
I can't cycle between too much and too little serotonin, having that gene defect.
But you don't want to confuse depression with anxiety, because it isn't finite right there.
I have depression.
Really?
Is it truly depression, or are you constantly nervous, and you're constantly worried, and you're
sad, because you're thinking of the worst case scenario all the time.
That's anxiety, that's not depression.
So a true depression from a decreased serotonin is going to be a billen colline that has
no explanation.
So there is a difference that you have to be careful with that, because you treat it completely
opposite from a dietary standpoint.
So a person with a true depression, you want more serotonin, right?
A person with a true depression, you want more of its precursors.
So a person that has, that is, a vegan diet, because they don't want to kill animals, or
whatever ethical reason they want to be on a vegan diet, or their friend is on it, so
they thought it'd be really good too.
And since they started this vegan diet five years ago, their depression has continued to
worsen.
It's probably because they have two little serotonin, following, they need to get some protein
in their body.
It's very tricky, that's why they work with some people that don't work with other people.
They work at different times, or they work for a period of time, or they stop working.
It's very difficult.
The other reason why you can get depression is this chiropractic pathway, and they better
not get into any more of that.
But you can pull a triptophan, what I call a triptophan, steel into the ideal pathway, and
you create a chiropractic acid, which can cause depression.
So that's probably the patient that doesn't work with a SRI, it's really the ideal pathway
type depression.
So excess, and you also test those patients, and you put a load of higher protein, and it actually
makes the worse, because they're steeling their triptophan down the ideal pathway.
So you can see how, can you see a little bit, that there's not just like a cookie cutter
approach to this?
And the more we try to take a cookie cutter approach, it only works out of very small percentage
of the patients, because you're not a cookie.
Yes.
Bipolar, there's actually a gene that increases the risk of bipolar.
It's a DAO gene, and so it causes, at least this is the theory right now, that it causes this
LAO gene to work, turn it on and off, basically, whether they have the defect or not.
So I think that the people with that DAO gene, and the LAO gene defect, have a greater degree
in bipolar, it gets afraid of that.
Yes, it is.
I think, I don't know if I put it on here or not, and I did not.
Probably on purpose.
That you got to be careful with, because the people are like, oh my god, I got to get to
get to run again.
How do you train it?
The same way I'm talking about, you have to, but if you like the diet, and there's some
different nutrition that you can help with it, there's a whole bunch of other glutamate
genes, and it's important with glutamate, because if ever I said, the thylene-conferent
cancer, glutamate-conferent cancer, too.
So if I'm not converting glutamate, which is this other gene, this glutamate, oh, the GLS
gene, I'm not converting glutamate-conferent glutamate, I'm going to have excess glutamate, and
that can feed cancer as well.
So that's why I'm very careful in how much glutamate, even though glutamate can be very healing
and a spell of testing, you got to be very careful how much you use.
So I typically don't use more than a gram a day, even though none of the cancer patients.
This is the NOS cheat that whoever causes NOS uncoupling, and that one you would treat even
if the person really doesn't have symptoms.
This is the biopterant, how it converts from biopterant to tetrahydra biopterant.